Зустріч, на яку ці люди чекали кілька років.
Для 76 українців, звільнених із в'язниць
проросійських сепаратистів, а також для їхніх близьких
обмін став справжнім подарунком на Новий рік.
А для президента Володимира Зеленського -
великим успіхом. Адже попри те, що повернути
з неволі вдалося далеко не всіх полонених,
цей обмін став першим за останні два роки
між офіційним Києвом і самопроголошеними "ДНР" і "ЛНР".
- Так, це умови... Умови "всіх на всіх".
Умови цього обміну.
Ми забирали наших героїв.
Я вважаю, що це складне було рішення,
рішення політичне, це правда. Я вважаю, що
наші бійці, наші військові, наші журналісти -
всі вони є героями. Я впевнений, що
для нас пріоритет - повернути наших людей.
Я з повагою ставлюся до всіх батьків і родичів,
які втратили близьких на Майдані.
Ми, на жаль, не можемо повернути тих,
кого вже немає. На жаль, ми не можемо це зробити,
але ми могли повернути живих. Я впевнений, що
це пріоритет. Я вам більше скажу.
Якби в мене було ще 100 беркутівців
і мені б запропонували одного розвідника,
я б їм віддав 100 беркутівців і повернув би живого розвідника.
Саме те, що Київ передав сепаратистам
п'ять колишніх бійців спецпідрозділу "Беркут",
яких підозрюють у масових розстрілах
протестувальників під час Євромайдану,
спровокувало гостру критику з боку низки
українських політиків. Особливо різко передачу
"беркутівців" сепаратистам засудила партія
"Європейська солідарність" п’ятого президента України Петра Порошенка.
З аналогічною критикою обміну силовиків,
підозрюваних у вбивствах демонстрантів,
відреагувала ще одна парламентська сила -
партія "Голос" рок-зірки Святослава Вакарчука.
А родичі загиблих напередодні обміну зажадали
виключити підозрюваних у розстрілах зі списків.
Проте бурхливої громадської дискусії
видача "беркутівців" напередодні новорічних свят
не викликала, а більшість українців просто радіють обміну.
- Наші люди мають бути вдома, зустрічати Новий рік
із родинами, з дітьми. Це перемога для України, для президента.
- Звісно, дуже раді, що люди змогли повернутися
до своїх сімей.
Але, з іншого боку, справа з майданівцями
не закрита, тому...
Це, звісно, я вважаю, що це промах влади -
відпустити "беркутівців".
- Я думаю, що це гарний крок,
це перший крок до якогось мирного врегулювання.
Я думаю, що це добре.
- Узагалі будь-який обмін полоненими - це вже якісь
дипломатичні відносини з ворогом
і позитивний рух, я сподіваюся,
в напрямку розв'язку конфлікту.
- Я радий, що люди вдома нарешті,
що вони будуть удома на Новий рік зі своїми батьками,
друзями, своїми жінками, дітьми.
Це дуже цінно в наш час.
- Знаєте, для тих, хто там,
і для тих, хто їх чекав тут,
це величезне досягнення.
А з точки зору великої політики української
це, може,
і поразка якась.
Чи стане обмін полоненими між Києвом
та підконтрольними Кремлю сепаратистами
першим кроком на шляху до миру, поки невідомо.
Водночас очевидно, що без цього обміну
шанси на прорив у мирному врегулюванні ситуації
наступного року були би значно нижчими.